le coup de pinceau est un geste
politique pour Katia cette russe peint
des poupées de Vladimir Poutine en tutu
c'est comme un rappel pour montrer que
Poutine est un personnage désolant il
n'est pas du tout effrayant
et genre
elle qui suit attentivement les
nouvelles de Russie n'a rien raté de la
progression rapide de la milice Wagner
vers Moscou puis son recul soudain
c'était clair qu'au final quelque chose
comme ça allait arriver il y aurait un
conflit au sein de ce groupe uscule
criminel parce que notre pays est dirigé
par des bandits ils forment tous un
grand groupe criminel organisé et ça
devait finir en conflit
il y a un an avec son fils Arseni 17 ans
en tant qu'artiste et surtout activiste
politique elle était en danger à Moscou
et craignait carsoni ne soit appelée à
combattre dans l'armée russe
son mari Denis et leur fille Sacha 23
ans les ont rejoint quelques mois plus
tard
il s'estime heureux d'avoir trouvé la
sécurité en France mais s'inquiète pour
leur famille et leurs amis restaient au
pays une crainte renforcée depuis que le
groupe Wagner dirigé par airgani
Prigogine a annoncé qu'il se rebellait
bien sûr qu'on avait un peu peur
on s'est dit qu'une fois de plus des
gens allaient mourir
je n'étais certain que d'une chose
c'est que brigogine n'irait pas tuer
Poutine et c'est ce qui s'est passé
toute ma vie Poutine a été Président je
ne connais pas d'autres modes de vie
Sacha étudie le graphisme elle va
commencer un nouveau travail en France
la Russie a une culture très riche et il
y avait beaucoup de grands événements
d'art contemporain aujourd'hui je ne
fais pas vraiment de projets à long
terme car tout évolue très vite
alors que la guerre entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine se poursuit Sacha et sa
famille comme les milliers de Russes
récemment arrivés en France vivent
toujours le jour sans certitude quant à
leur éventuel retour au pays